this video was made possible by nebula
use the link in the description to
support my channel directly and get
early access to my video on how the TV
show succession films its car scenes Tom
WS kids my name is Walter Hartwell White
I must know your
name my name when you meet someone new
your name is the first thing you tell
them it's on your birth certificate your
Tombstone and on every email in between
to forget your name is to lose your
sense of self a dilemma that completely
breaks SpongeBob's brain we thre out
inside
so it's no surprise that character names
in movie and TV names not just given but
chosen by screenwriters play a vital
role in storytelling it's not always
easy analyzing something like names but
as the saying goes you can't make a
tolet without breaking some Gregs
looking at naming choices can reveal
hidden meanings like how Neo in The
Matrix comes from the Greek root meaning
new and is also an anagram of the word
one hinting at Mr Anderson's future role
as a prophet but names are more than
just clever word play or foreshadowing
the weight of names including the way
they're used how they sound and even how
they change defines some of the most
iconic stories in film and television to
really know a character you have to know
what they're called my character and the
clue to who my character is is contained
within his name as well the importance
of naming and storytelling goes as far
back as the 1996 movie Romeo and Juliet
in the movie's most famous scene Juliet
professes what's in a
name that which we call a rose by any
other word would smell a sweet Juliet
made this claim to protest the violent
feud between her family the capulets and
her lover Romeo's family the monu to her
the Family Feud is senseless based
solely on the arbitrary distinction of a
last name and she's definitely on to
something the opening line of the movie
describes the families as aike in digity
so right from the start the families are
similar regardless of the name
difference and Romeo takes no issue with
ditching his name for her Romeo and a
mon neither F made defeated the dislike
but these starcross lovers are ignorant
to the reality of their situation they
may claim that their names don't matter
but if you know how the movie ends they
clearly do so this scene gets at the
core contradiction of naming on one hand
names seem arbitrary a rose smells sweet
no matter what you call it and anyone
gets to change their name as an adult if
they so choose but the story of Romeo
and Juliet is at odds with this idea
because their different names have
tangible real world consequences this
contradiction in names in Romeo and
Juliet shows why names are so hard to
talk about at what point do they go for
meaningful to arbitrary the TV show
succession follows the Roy a wealthy
family that owns a large media
conglomerate and the title succession
points at the show's main drama the
patriarch Logan Roy deciding who to name
as his successor of the company the show
is full of unique and deliberate name
choices which has led to lots of online
discussion on what they mean a recent
viral Tik Tok theorizes that Tom Wan's
character is named after Bill wamsgans
the only baseball player to complete an
unassisted triple play at a World Series
the theory goes that writers named Tom
after Bill W scans because Tom also
performs an unassisted triple play by
knocking out three opponents during a
pivotal board vote succession executive
producer Frank Rich calls this Theory a
happy coincidence and while I do think
it's a fun way to look at Tom's
character there's another better way to
analyze Tom's last name and names in
general that not only tells us more but
is also hidden in plain
sight there's many theories on where
Darth Vader's name comes from Vader in
German means father his name is
literally Darth father and these
theories may be correct but they
Overlook a simpler much more important
fact about the name it sounds scary a
young Jedi named Darth Vader R is among
the most menacing of sounds that's why
they call it murder and not muckduck
when we analyze names it's easy to
forget that like lighting camera work or
editing a technical explanation doesn't
fully capture the visceral feeling of
the creative Choice when we hear a name
we don't necessarily know some Easter
egg translation of the name or its
association with some other person yet
we do feel how that name sounds the B
sounds in the name b blow baggin
indicates a bubbly gentle character
which makes it all the more startling
when we see the corrupting effect of the
ring so with this framing how does the
name WS Gans sound Mr woms Gans I hope
I'm saying that correctly it's just
weird hard to say hard to sit in the
mouth sort of name it's sort of strange
and not quite right he's a sort of
interloper in that family and a family
called Roy maybe some people watching
succession did know about the baseball
player Bill wamsgans and maybe a writer
did sneak that reference into the name
but the sound of his last name matters
more because listeners feel and
internalize the difference between the
dynastic and simple Roy and the chunky
hardto pronounce and forgettable wom
scans Tom last name last name uh weird I
don't think I ever got his last but
Tom's last name isn't just a subtle nod
the character himself demonstrates a
clear understanding of the importance or
the lack of importance of his name in
one brief moment Tom asks shiv how they
should combine or change their last
names once married did you think again
about whether we want to go woms or Roy
wsans or as I said I'd be willing to
just drop traditional and go Tom Roy
even on the way to their wedding Tom and
shiv haven't come to an agreement on
where Tom fits in the Roy lineage and
Tom is willing to drop his name
completely and switch to Roy this
proposition reflects Tom's strange
relationship with the family marrying
shiv is not just for love but also a
power grab a way to cement his place in
the dynasty this moment in succession
reveals another truth about naming you
can learn a lot about a character by how
they try and often fail to change their
name say my
name Heisenberg you're goddamn
right everybody has a name on their
birth certificate but that's rarely the
full story to prove my point what is
this guy's name the answer depends on
who you ask his name is Walter White but
he's also Walt Mr White dad ww and even
Heisenberg the alter ego name he invents
for for himself each of these names
represents a different side of the
show's protagonist whether it's as
father husband business partner or drug
kingpin in the show Walt's everchanging
name reflects his complicated and
everchanging relationship with Jesse
it's funny that even as they break the
law and cook meth together Jesse still
refers to him like he did in high school
cheddar Mr White fat stacks Dead
Presidents cash money but the
relationship occasionally shifts in a
change of tone Jesse breaks his comedic
streak and changes names to show his new
power over Walter White you need me more
than I need you Walt in a handful of
scenes Walter even pretends to be
Jesse's dad confirming that the
relationship isn't just personal or
teacher student but also father son and
as Walt adopts a more paternal role in
Jesse's life he grows distant from his
actual son Walter Jr most clearly shown
as expected in changing his name from
Walter Jr to Flynn erasing his dad from
his name Flynn so a name change
represents a transformation in The
Matrix before becoming a prophet Neo
went by Mr Anderson co-director Lily
wowski has said that the story of The
Matrix is a trans allegory so it's no
surprise that like during a gender
transition name changing plays an
important role as agent Smith repeatedly
dead names him Neo reaffirms his real
name showing the full adoption of his
true identity my name is Neo since name
changing shows a character
transformation the failure to change a
name means the opposite when a rename
attempt doesn't work it shows that the
character failed to change their
identity and both literally and
figuratively make a name of themselves
you can call me Drew no I'm not going to
call you that hello Greg I'm actually
going by Gregory now but uh throughout
the movie ladybird the main character
rejects her birth name of Christine in
favor of a new one my name is ladybird
uh well actually it's not and it's
ridiculous call me Lady Bird like you
said you would but by the end of the
movie She reverts back to her birth name
it's me Christine it's the name name you
gave me it's a good one so the initial
insistance on the name ladybird instead
of her birth name reflects the
transition period Christina Stuck In
struggling to make sense of her
Sacramento upbringing ditching the name
ladybird at College shows that the
character has grown grateful for and
even Embraces where she came from so it
makes sense that in succession the two
characters just outside of the Roy orbit
Tom wamsgans and Gregory Hirsch
repeatedly struggle with their names and
with name changing in Greg's
introduction Logan gets his name wrong
showing just how far Greg has to go
cousin Craig it's it's Greg no no Greg
hey Gregory at first glance the issues
these characters have with their names
may just seem like clever symbolism but
names mean much more than that in fact
they get you in the building good to
bear in mind that you're only here
because your name matches the one card
on the building in many ways succession
isn't the story of power or money or
family it's a story about naming yeah I
think Dad put my name on there it's
housekeeping I think it's a name on a
piece of paper ship and not just naming
a successor but name changing and name
calling so it's no surprise that a show
obsessed with names also holds within it
the core contradiction of names names
are just words on a piece of paper yet a
name on a piece of paper means
everything to the Roy children okay so
can I be the name on the piece of paper
bit of content and a brand name bit of
content in a brand name is kind of the
whole game isn't it in season 4 Kendall
can't tell whether Logan meant to
underline or cross out his name when
naming a successor showrunner Jesse
Armstrong has gone on the record saying
which it was which I'll link in the
description but I think analyzing this
moment so literally misses the point of
naming both in this scene and naming in
general what Logan meant to do doesn't
matter as much as the very real pain
that the ambiguity of naming causes Tom
and the Roy children like all of us may
sometimes pretend that names don't
matter but at the end of the day they
yearn for their name on Logan's piece of
paper despite the children in succession
claiming that words are just complicated
airflow they're wrong who Logan named a
successor clearly matters to them Juliet
and ROM and Juliet and Kendall in
succession can claim that names are
pointless that they're purely symbolic
but that's not how they play out in
reality they lead to Juliet's death and
Kendall losing all meaning in his life
name changes happen at life's most
transformative moments getting married
going to college or realizing your true
identity it's equal parts fickle and
radical there's a lot in a name on a
piece of paper so I hope you like your
name because it sure does matter and if
you didn't think so before I hope that
now you see
it thank you for the chicken another
challenge with talking about names is
that I'm stuck analyzing dialogue
instead of visual elements of the scene
which is why I made a companion video
about how succession uses creative
cinematic techniques to highlight the
tension between Tom and shiv in their
various car scenes and you can get early
access to that video right now on nebula
thanks to nebula I could make this video
analyzing long segments of a scene
without worrying about YouTube
demonetizing it nebula is a subscription
service buil by me and hundreds of your
favorite creators including my favorites
Abigail Thorne Patrick Willams and H
bomber guy which gives you access to
adree videos and exclusive nebula
Originals by subscribing now you'll get
access to nebula classes a brand new
part of the bundle where creators reveal
their secrets and teach you how to
create if you follow my link in the
description you'll get 40% off an annual
subscription which comes out to 250 a
month which I honestly believe is the
best streaming deal out there today so
go to the description to support my
channel and to watch my nebula first
video on how the TV show succession
films its car scenes thanks for watching